moi je pense que la vérité c'est que
françois hollande n'est plus on peut les
plus audibles
quel que soit ce qu'ils disent
aujourd'hui mais sur les tomber si bas
accor qui n'est plus audible pour un
président de la république c'est quand
même un problème c'est quand même un
tout petit problème pour quelqu'un qui
est président on peut jurer ça pour un
président de la république c'est
compliqué n'est pas audible
internationale omi lui demande carole
justement vous pensez que c'est une ut
valeur il a vécu prises il l'a prise
il s'est exprimé dans un livre étrange
et curieux il a revu beaucoup de vos
collègues pendant des dizaines et des
dizaines de fois et il dit des trucs qui
ne sont absolument pas compatible avec
ce qu'il dit pour le privé et le public
on voit bien que on voit bien que tout
ça et il peut se prononcer j'en sais
rien je suis à la gauche de le dire
en tout cas ils ne donnent pas envie
rien eh oui mon avis que est un échec
c'est un échec total dont jean sûr et je
ne sais pas quel notre intérêt
vous avez un avis alors lequel je pense
que je pense que l'ina ina peau enfin il
n'a qu'une koch aucune case pour être
candidat à la présidence de la
république
c'est un échec total aujourd'hui les
français doutent de sa compétence
être président de la république c'est
quand même un doute assez profond il n'a
pas respecté sa parole il a eu un
comportement le moins qu'on puisse dire
absolument étonnant donc je crois qu'il
faut tourner la page